Je ne répondais jamais.
Je me contentais de supprimer les mails.
Je pensais que les expéditeurs et moi n'avions rien en commun.
Ils ne me comprenaient pas
et je ne les comprenais pas.
Puis, un jour, une de mes collègues au parlement a dit
que je devrais conserver les mails de haine.
« Quand quelque chose t'arrivera, cela donnera une piste à la police. »
(Rires)
J'ai remarqué qu'elle a dit « quand quelque chose t'arrivera » et pas « si ».
Parfois, des lettres de haine étaient également envoyées à mon domicile.
Plus j'étais impliquée dans le débat public,
plus je recevais de mails de haine et de menaces.
Après un certain temps, j'ai créé un compte secret
et j'ai dû prendre des précautions supplémentaires pour protéger ma famille.
En 2010, un nazi a commencé à me harceler.
C'était un homme qui avait attaqué des femmes musulmanes dans la rue.
Avec le temps, cela a grandement empiré.
J'étais au zoo avec mes enfants et le téléphone sonnait constamment.
C'était le nazi.
J'ai eu l'impression qu'il était proche.
Nous sommes rentrés.
Quand nous sommes arrivés,
mon fils a demandé : « Pourquoi te déteste-t-il autant, maman,
alors qu'il ne te connaît même pas ? »
« Certaines personnes sont simplement stupides », ai-je dit.
A l'époque, je pensais vraiment que c'était une réponse intelligente.
Je soupçonne que c'est la réponse que la plupart d'entre nous donneraient.
Les autres --
ils sont stupides, ignorants, ont subi un lavage de cerveau.
Nous sommes les gentils et eux les méchants, point final.
Quelques semaines plus tard, j'étais chez un ami
et j'étais contrariée et en colère
au sujet de la haine et du racisme auxquels je faisais face.
C'est lui qui a suggéré que j'appelle ces personnes
et que je leur rende visite.
« Ils me tueraient », ai-je dit.
« Ils n'attaqueraient jamais un membre du parlement danois.
Et puis, s'ils te tuaient, tu deviendrais une martyre.
(Rires)
C'est gagnant-gagnant pour toi. »
Son conseil était si inattendu,
que, quand je suis rentrée,
j'ai allumé mon ordinateur
et ouvert le dossier où j'avais gardé tous les messages de haine.
Il y en avait des centaines.
Des mails commençant par des mots comme « terroriste »,
« enturbannée »,
« rat », « pute ».
J'ai décidé de contacter celui qui m'en avait envoyé le plus.
Son nom était Ingolf.
J'ai décidé de l'appeler une seule fois afin de pouvoir dire que j'avais essayé.
A ma grande stupéfaction,
il a répondu au téléphone.
J'ai lâché : « Bonjour, je suis Özlem. Vous m'avez envoyé tant de mails de haine.
Nous ne nous connaissons pas.
Je me demandais si je pouvais venir pour qu'on boive un café ensemble
et que l'on en discute ? »
(Rires)
Ce fut le silence sur la ligne.
Puis il a dit :
« Je dois demander à ma femme. »
(Rires)
Quoi ?
Le raciste a une femme ?
(Rires)
Quelques jours plus tard, nous nous sommes rencontrés chez lui.
Je n'oublierai jamais le moment où il a ouvert sa porte d'entrée
et a tendu sa main pour que je la serre.
J'étais si déçue.
(Rires)
Car il ne ressemblait en rien à ce que j'avais imaginé.
J'avais imaginé quelqu'un d'horrible --
une maison sale et en désordre.
Ce n'était pas le cas.
Sa maison sentait le café
qui était servi dans un service identique à celui de mes parents.
J'ai fini par rester deux heures et demie.
Nous avions tant de choses en commun.
Même nos préjugés étaient similaires.
(Rires)
Ingolf m'a dit que quand il attendait le bus
et que le bus s'arrêtait à 10 mètres de lui,
c'était parce que le chauffeur était un « enturbanné ».
J'ai reconnu ce sentiment.
Quand j'étais jeune,
que j'attendais le bus
et qu'il s'arrêtait à 10 mètres de moi,
j'étais sûre que le chauffeur était raciste.
Quand je suis rentrée,
j'étais ambivalente au sujet de mon expérience.
D'un côté, j'appréciais Ingolf.
C'était facile et plaisant de lui parler,
mais d'un autre côté,
je ne pouvais pas supporter l'idée d'avoir tant en commun
avec quelqu'un qui avait des opinions si racistes.
Graduellement,
douloureusement,
j'ai réalisé
que j'avais autant jugé les gens m'ayant envoyé des mails de haine
qu'ils m'avaient eux-mêmes jugée.
Ce fut le début de ce que j'appelle #cafédialogue.
Je prends le café
avec des gens qui m'ont dit des choses terribles
afin d'essayer de comprendre pourquoi ils détestent les gens comme moi
alors qu'ils ne me connaissent même pas.
J'ai fait cela les huit dernières années.
La grande majorité des gens que j'approche acceptent une rencontre.
Ce sont surtout des hommes,
mais j'ai aussi rencontré des femmes.
J'ai adopté la règle suivante : toujours les rencontrer chez eux
afin d'exprimer dès le début que je leur fais confiance.
J'amène toujours à manger car, quand on mange ensemble,
il est plus facile de trouver nos points communs
et d'instaurer la paix.
En chemin, j'ai appris quelques précieuses leçons.
Les gens qui ont envoyé des messages de haine sont des travailleurs,
des maris, des femmes,
des parents comme vous et moi.
Je ne dis pas que leur comportement est acceptable,
mais j'ai appris à me distancer des opinions haineuses
sans me distancer de la personne qui exprime ces opinions.
J'ai découvert
que les gens auxquels je rends visite ont aussi peur des inconnus
que j'avais peur d'eux avant de commencer à m'inviter pour un café.
Durant ces rencontres, un thème spécifique revient constamment.
Cela montre que cela importe peu que je parle à un humaniste, à un raciste,
à un homme, à une femme,
à un musulman ou à un athéiste.
Ils semblent tous penser
que les autres sont responsables de la haine
et de la généralisation des groupes.
Ils croient tous que les autres doivent arrêter la démonisation.
Ils pointent du doigt les politiciens, les médias, leurs voisins
ou le chauffeur de bus qui s'arrête à 10 mètres.
Quand j'ai demandé : « Et vous ?
Que pouvez-vous faire ? »,
leur réponse était généralement :
« Que puis-je faire ?
Je n'ai aucune influence.
Je n'ai aucun pouvoir. »
Ce sentiment m'est familier.
Durant une grande partie de ma vie,
je pensais également n'avoir aucun pouvoir et aucune influence --
même quand j'étais membre du parlement danois.
Aujourd'hui, je sais que la réalité est différente.
Nous avons tous du pouvoir et de l'influence,
nous ne devons jamais,
jamais sous-estimer notre propre potentiel.
Les rencontres #cafédialogue m'ont appris
que les gens de toutes convictions politiques peuvent diaboliser
ceux ayant des opinions différentes.
Je sais de quoi je parle.
Quand j'étais enfant, je détestais plusieurs groupes.
A l'époque, mes opinions religieuses étaient très extrêmes.
Mais mon amitié avec des Turcs, des Danois, des juifs et des racistes
m'a vaccinée contre mes propres préjugés.
J'ai grandi dans une famille ouvrière
et j'ai rencontré en chemin nombre de gens qui ont insisté pour me parler.
Ils ont changé mes opinions.
Ils m'ont modelée
en tant que citoyenne démocratique et bâtisseuse de ponts.
Si vous voulez éviter la haine et la violence,
nous devons parler à autant de gens que possible,
pendant aussi longtemps que possible,
en étant aussi ouvert que possible.
Cela ne peut être réalisé qu'à travers des débats,
des conversations critiques
et le fait d'insister pour avoir un dialogue ne diabolisant pas les gens.
Je vais vous poser une question.
Je vous invite à y réfléchir ce soir et dans les jours à venir,
mais vous devez être honnête envers vous-même.
Cela devrait être facile, personne ne le saura.
La question est...
qui diabolisez-vous ?
Pensez-vous que les sympathisants du président américain Trump
sont déplorables ?